foreign
family friends and supporters of
assassinated presidential candidate
Fernando Villa vicencio accompanied his
hearse to the cemetery demanding Justice
the people want to see the remains of
the only man who had guts in this
country there are many many in Ecuador
but Villa vicencio was the only one with
the courage to confront those criminals
the mafia
many blame police forces whom via
vicencio had accused of working for drug
mafias for not providing security
despite the numerous death threats
against him
at a rally earlier this month the former
congressman and journalist said he
wouldn't wear a bulletproof vest and
vowed to hunt down organized crime
come and get me here I am they said
they'd break me here I am let the drug
leaders come with their gunmen the time
for threats is over
authorities have arrested six Colombians
whom they say were hired gunmen violent
crime and drug trafficking have turned
Ecuador into one of the Region's most
dangerous countries
when there's a crime like this you have
to ask yourself who benefits and
obviously it's the other candidates who
will capture villover senzo's votes and
the one who has hurt the most is Louisa
Gonzalez the candidate who was in the
lead up until now in the polls because
there's a campaign to accuse her party
of being behind us although there is no
evidence
is from the same left-wing political
party as its exiled leader Rafael Correa
there is no clear evidence as to who was
behind the killing or whether there is a
political motive as many are claiming
but what is likely is that the killing
of a presidential candidate who was a
staunch enemy a former Ecuadorian
president Rafael Correa
20th presidential elections
despite calls for them to be postponed
electoral authorities say they'll go
ahead regardless
Fernando you will live in our hearts and
in all of Ecuador
was polling fifth amongst the eight
presidential candidates but his murder
has sparked fear amongst remaining
candidates and ecuadorians at large who
are looking for answers but especially
for a leader capable of ending the
country's uncontrollable violence
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Quito Ecuador